FEMALE SPEAKER: And I'm super
excited to introduce to you two
of our great speakers
who are here today.
And they're going to talk
about net neutrality.
They're going to talk about
the importance of access
of internet.
The first speaker we have
today is Nikhil Pahwa.
Thank you, Nikhil,
for joining us.
We're very excited.
Nikhil is a co-founder of the
SaveTheInternet.in coalition,
which galvanized the support of
over a million Indian citizens
for net neutrality.
He is also founder of
MediaNama, a tech blog
about startups in India.
He led the movement to rally the
entire ecosystem of startups,
IT university professors, and
major uprising of citizens
to demand net
neutrality and defeat
zero-rating products in India.
It was a remarkable
citizen effort,
especially because he
co-led it as a volunteer.
So we're really excited to have
you here and learn from you,
hear more about the movement.
And we're super
excited and really
looking forward to the talk.
So thank you for joining us.
Second, we have,
with us, Ritu Sharma,
who is the co-founder of
Social Media for Nonprofits
and founder of SDG Nexus.
Ritu spearheads the
efforts of SDG Nexus,
a multi-stakeholder physical
and digital global development
platform for leveraging access
to internet from the demand
and adoption site to accelerate
the implementation of the UN
sustainable development
goals, SDGs.
She works with various
governments, the UN,
international NGOs, technology
corporations, World Bank,
and ICT, for development
coalitions around the world,
to facilitate adoption
efforts in the global south.
So thank you, Ritu,
for joining us.
Super excited to have you here.
Let me talk a little bit about
the format of the talk today.
We'll request Ritu to
kickstart the discussion
and talk about the
importance of internet
and why we all
should care about it.
And then we'll request
Nikhil to come up on stage
and hear, from him, about how he
co-led this remarkable citizen
effort in India.
And then we'll request both
of you, both Nikhil and Ritu,
to come back up on stage
for a structured Q&A.
And then we'll make
sure that we're
spending at least the last 10
minutes in audience questions.
So with that, let's kickstart.
And Ritu, please come
on up and kickstart
the discussion and the talk.
RITU SHARMA: Anamika,
thank you very
much for hosting and making
this platform available for us
to come and share educational
information with people that
work at Google
around the world who
are just as equally passionate
about access to internet
as we are.
So thank you for making this
time and this opportunity
available to us.
And thank you for hosting
us in your brand new campus.
It's the first time
I'm here, so thank you.
It's beautiful.
What separates me from
a woman my age in India,
where I grew up, in
Jabalpur, potentially not
more than 50 miles away
from where I grew up,
is the access to
opportunities, and many times,
something as simple as
someone believing in me.
I'm no smarter,
and I'm definitely
not anymore hardworking,
than that woman who's
working, potentially, more
than a full-time job of 14
hours a day in the field.
She's also supporting
her family.
She's supporting her children.
She's cooking and
cleaning, all that
with a very little
bit that she has
compared to what I have today.
And interestingly,
what separates
us is not to my intelligence
or my education,
it's really my access
to opportunities.
And this is what this
talk is about today.
I came to this
country 16 years ago,
enabled by my access internet,
to look for and apply
for colleges in the US.
I applied to 250 colleges.
I got some sort of a
response from about, maybe,
three to five colleges
that wrote back.
And one, in particular,
one Lakeland College
in Sheboygan, Wisconsin--
if you know Wisconsin
or if you know the
US, you know it's
in the middle of cornfields--
only that college
was receptive to my request.
I negotiated heavily.
And read that as, I pleaded
extensively for them to give me
a partial scholarship.
I got a partial
scholarship from them.
I made a very big
speech with my sister,
who helped me practice,
on our roof at our home,
to my dad, a passionate
speech about why
it was important for me
to leave India, and come,
and make something of myself.
We practiced for days.
And then, one final day,
I said that to my dad,
that I wanted to go.
I have admission at a school.
And I have to be honest, I lied.
I said, I have full scholarship.
And you just need to do a
little bit to get me there.
So the long and short of that
is my dad mortgaged everything
he had, his scooter, his pension
fund, and a small piece of land
that we owned.
And I got here.
So I came to this country.
And I arrived, and I
was like, OK, I'm here.
Now what?
I worked four jobs,
starting at 4:00 AM,
milking cows in Wisconsin,
because I had lied, to my dad,
that I had full
scholarship, which I didn't.
Moved on to attending
school from 8:00 to 6:00.
And 6:00 to 10:00, I worked
at a tech lab at my school,
where I did all of my homework
and all of my education
online, because, again,
I didn't have the money.
So I didn't have books.
So I would spend, in the
evening, 6:00 to 10:00,
time learning about the
different subject matter.
And I would answer my
questions in my test
based on the
knowledge I got there.
And occasionally,
I would also get
books loaned from my
teacher and my classmates.
And then, after a few
weeks of getting a rhythm,
I learned how to make HTML
websites in that 6:00 to 10:00
time zone.
And that led to my
next career, which
is, a couple of months
later, I worked from 10:00 PM
to 12:00 AM in the morning
at a nearby resort where
I maintained websites,
just simple HTML changes.
So I worked pretty around the
clock for this opportunity.
Of course, human will, my
sheer human will, my passion,
coming from a family
that supported
education and basic
understanding of English,
helped me quite a bit.
But if you see this
thread, internet
has played a very, very
big role in my being
here today, from
getting to this country,
to putting myself through
school without books,
to getting my very
first opportunity
to work in website development.
I went on, later, to start
a web development company
with an offshore development
unit in India and in Romania.
I made websites for small
businesses, Realtors,
and nonprofits but a few years.
And a couple career
iterations later,
I launched a nonprofit,
Social Media for Nonprofits.
Social Media for
Nonprofits has served
over 10,000 people in 14
cities in four countries now,
in helping nonprofits
around the world use
social media and digital
media to meet their mission,
to increase awareness of their
work, to raise more funds,
and also, to advocate
for their causes.
I'm also in the
process of starting
the next chapter
of my career, where
I'm working with
several UN agencies,
with several governments, with
several corporations, and also,
a very strong group of NGOs
on the ground in increasing
the adoption of internet.
Because if you get internet
into these rural [INAUDIBLE]
and grounds, that is
not enough if people
don't know how to access
it, interact with it,
use it for making
positive change.
So that's the next
chapter I have.
And as you can see from this
thread, a lot of my success
has been enabled by access
to this great resource.
Internet has been the
greatest enabler of our times.
It has enabled the
largest hospitality
company in Silicon
Valley, Airbnb,
which does not own any hotels.
It has enabled the success
of the largest transportation
company in the world right
now, which owns no fleets.
It has enabled the success of
the largest media organization
that doesn't hire journalists,
per se, as a form of media.
And of course, we are at the
campus of Google, which is also
the internet search engine.
So as you can see, internet
is a great enabler.
It creates a
frictionless platform
between supplies and demand,
so buyers and sellers.
An open, and unrestricted,
and accessible internet
is crucial for enabling the
greatest number of people
around the world to have this
access to the same opportunity
that you and I have,
people who are here,
in this room, people who are
watching us in the livecast.
The digital revolution
has two core components.
It taps the underutilized
assets and the access
to open markets which is
enabled through internet.
So in the case of Airbnb,
it's enabling people
to use unutilized space and
find people who can use that.
In the case of Uber, it is
taking the underutilized time
on the car and the
phone to enable that
between buyers and sellers.
In the case of the
digital south, which
is where we come
from, which is where
we are working, in 14
countries, for our pilot
in the next couple of months,
what is the underutilized
asset there?
A lot of people don't have
a house that they can rent.
A lot of people don't
have access to a car
that they can use to
partake in the opportunity
that the internet represents.
So how do we take
this resource and use
that to unleash the potential
of people on the ground?
And what I'd like to say is,
as you saw in my example--
and you will reflect
on your own lives--
what asset that we, each
and every one of us, have
is a human potential.
So what I foresee happening
is, with the internet,
through our work that
we're working on,
is to tap the underutilized
potential of people
in the global south who
are incredibly resilient,
incredibly hardworking.
You cannot argue with their
work ethic, as you can see,
from millions of people that
are working on the ground 14,
18-hour days--
extreme hard work.
So with that, I
want to say, this
is what the opportunity is for
people in the global south.
And our work together, as
suppliers, as public policy,
as NGO, is to take this
access to access and access
to opportunity to
people on the ground
so they can be our future
creators and producers,
and not just consumers.
So they're not just
people who are searching.
They're not just people
who are creating content.
They're also people
who are improving
their lives, lifting themselves
and others out of poverty.
With the backdrop
of this, I'd like
to invite my guest, whose
work I'm very inspired by,
to be able to do what he
has led and to inspire
so many people to support
this open, unrestricted, and
accessible internet for all.
So I'd love to invite Nikhil.
Please join us, and share
your background, your vision,
and also, a little bit about the
net neutrality debate in India.
And with that, it's yours.
NIKHIL PAHWA: So
just to take off
from what you were
talking about, the access
to opportunity, imagine if
you had only one site to surf
to choose colleges from.
And imagine if we had
only one or two sites
to get content from.
So who controls
access to content
and who controls
access to websites
essentially controls
our opportunities,
because they can limit
our opportunities.
And that's essentially what
the battle for net neutrality
is about.
It's also important to remember,
just as you experienced,
you created.
You created web pages, right?
So all of us are users.
And we're both creators
and consumers, and not just
receivers of content
and information.
So it's important
that this entire world
gets the opportunity to
create content and effectively
create competition so that
everyone tries to better one
another.
And that's what takes
the human race forward
in terms of providing
information, knowledge,
perspective, products.
And that's why I think
companies like Google
and people who build
online businesses, who
ship code are essentially people
who are now building the world.
So I think the most important
thing about the internet,
for me, is that it's a
free-roam space, that we
can go wherever we want.
And often, access-based
businesses--
if you look at TV and
cable TV-- they're
built around restricting
access and then monetizing
those restrictions.
So that's essentially
what, we realized,
is happening in India, what
the carriers were trying to do,
that they were trying to
restrict access to information.
You know, India's finally got
the internet growth growing.
In the last one year
alone, one research
tells us that we've added
about 100 million users.
I'm coming from a time
when we had about 25 to 30
to 35 million users.
That's when I started up.
And we've just seen a stupendous
growth over the last four
years.
So about 25% of India's internet
user base of 400 million users
has been added in the
last one year alone.
So there are new users
who are coming online
and who are experiencing
the internet.
Now, what they get access to
is what effectively defines
the future of the
internet in India,
because they need the same kind
of access that you and I have.
They need the same opportunity
that you and I have.
But that's not what
the carriers want.
As a reporter, as a blogger
who looks at the tech space,
I've been seeing, over
the last few years,
about how carriers have been
asking for interconnect charges
from every single website.
They want every website that
gets accessed to pay them fees.
And that's dangerous,
because not everything online
is a business.
I'm sure many of you
contribute to open source.
Many of you write articles
or edit Wikipedia.
We don't do it for money.
It's not part of our jobs.
But it's something that we
contribute to essentially make
sure that the space grows.
And so to just look
at the internet
as pure market and
purely as a business
is extremely dangerous, but
that's how the carriers think.
So what we noticed was that,
when the new government came
into power in India in 2014,
the telecom lobby in India
prepared a five-point
agenda for them to look at.
And part of that agenda
was, for the first time,
interconnect charges
from internet companies
and, essentially, websites.
And that's when I started
taking this seriously.
I mean, I'm someone
who started a blog
because I love the tech space.
At that point, I
couldn't get a job.
And I built it into a business.
So we've all struggled our
way to that opportunity.
And here are the
carriers, saying, hey,
if you want to
build something, you
have to come and take
permission from us.
You need to negotiate with us
about how much you'll pay us.
And this push from the
carriers let to a seminar one
on the 5th of April in 2014.
And eventually, towards
the end of the year,
India's largest carrier decided
to carve out internet telephony
and VoIP into a
separate data pack
so people would have
to buy that separately,
which is a net neutrality
violation as far as we see it.
And the regulators
said, you know
what, we need to create
a policy around this,
so we will have a
consultation process.
When the consultation
paper came out,
it was-- disastrous
is the way I see it,
because it asked whether every
single website in the world
should have to buy a
license to be accessible
in India, about
whether carriers should
be allowed to charge
differently for accessing
separate websites.
And that's an environment which
gives power to the carriers
and takes away from
the freedom that we
have to build what we want
without thinking about
whether anyone
will use it or not.
On the internet, sites
find their own market,
because there's a
market everywhere.
It is a universal, undivided
space, so to speak.
And we saw this push coming in.
So what we did was we started
calling up friends for help.
And we have lots of friends
in the internet space.
I write about it.
I have friends who code.
I have lawyers who care
about freedom of speech.
And we've worked on free
speech online over the years.
And we built, together,
a loose volunteer group.
There was a tech team
that was building sites.
There was a content team
that was working on informing
people about what was going on.
And there was a
legal and policy team
that was preparing a submission
to be given to the regulator.
And we saw what happened in
the US, with net neutrality,
in the case of John Oliver,
the great video that he did.
So we thought, hey, maybe we
should try something similar.
And we contacted a bunch
of stand-up comedians
in India who came in and
built a really funny video.
They put it together.
They released it.
And all of a sudden,
we made people
care about net neutrality.
Now, remember, this is a
country where people didn't
know what net neutrality meant.
They didn't know why they
should care about it.
And we made them care.
In 12 days after we launched,
we got a million people
to email the regulator.
That's never happened in
the history of India before.
And the pressure was
put on the government,
on the regulator through
the-- we had, eventually,
by the end if it, about
850 startup founders who
wrote to the regulator
and to the prime minister,
asking him to protect
net neutrality.
And in a country
where people usually
don't care about these things--
because even with startups,
because I've been looking
at them for a long time,
they tend to react after
the policy is made.
But because of the
information that we shared
and because of how we made
people understand about how
it would impact
them and the future
of the internet in India,
they all got involved.
And I think we're at
a moment in history,
in our country, where we
have a large number of users
coming online.
And it's important for
us to work together
to ensure that the freedom of
access that we've grown up with
is a freedom that they also get.
And it's not just India
where this has to happen.
This has to happen
around the world.
We're seeing instances
where carriers
don't want to be commodity
businesses and deal in data.
One of the carriers, I
remember, he actually said,
we're moving out of
the data business,
and we're moving into
the internet business.
And what that meant
was, they wanted
to start selling
access to websites
instead of selling data.
And imagine what that does
for a space where people
like us combine audio,
video, and text,
and create completely new
consumer experiences that give
people reasons to come online.
Imagine if someone started
controlling whether, oh, you're
a video service, so you
have to pay this much,
or, you're an internet
telephony service,
so you have to buy a license.
Oh, you're just doing text?
OK.
You don't need to pay much.
How does that experience the
future of access in the world?
And shouldn't every single
personal who comes online
have the same kind of access
to opportunity as we did?
So that was our fight.
And last month, the
regulator ruled in our favor.
And I think India's
got, possibly,
the strongest net neutrality
regulation in the world right
now.
But for us, the
danger is that this
is only there for two years.
The regulator wants to keep the
option open of revisiting this.
So I think that
precedence of openness
and that idea of one internet
for the entire world,
where that isn't fragmented
by either different types
of access with
different carriers
or by different
countries getting access
to different types
of sites, I think,
that oneness that unites the
world, which is the internet,
I think we need to fight
to maintain that now.
RITU SHARMA: Thank
you very much.
What an inspiration,
isn't it, especially,
to see the number of
people that came together
as they came together
in supporting this
and getting the
awareness-- so, amazing.
I have a set of questions.
And then, we'll take
questions from the audience.
But I will start with
a couple simple ones.
And isn't some access
better than no access?
And this is the most
common criticism
of what's going on in
India, where it says,
why is it fair for people
who, like us, have access
to internet, access
to technology,
for us to advocate on behalf of
those who have nothing, to have
an all or nothing approach?
NIKHIL PAHWA: So
I think this was
a point that was made
at the TRAI seminar
as well, saying that it's
impossible for us, for anybody
to understand what
the internet is about.
Because if you're restricted to
accessing only a certain amount
of sites, then, that
limits your understanding
of what you can get.
Search is a great
example of something
that allows people to discover.
And if search keeps people
within a closed group of sites,
imagine how they would never
be able to discover anything.
So I think what
we're looking at is,
how do we bring more and more
people online and give them
access.
But the question
is, access to what.
And what matters is
access to the entire web.
So we shouldn't
foreclose the options of,
for example, what is called
equal rating from Mozilla,
which is, can we find ways
of subsidizing data costs
or giving people free data so
they can access the entire web.
We shouldn't get stuck
in this false dichotomy
that you need to choose
between universal access
and net neutrality.
Because there are ways, such as
ad-supported internet access,
such as what Google's doing
with Wi-Fi at railway stations,
where people essentially get
access to the entire web.
Let's not make them-- let's
not create a new digital divide
where there will be some
people who get access
to a limited part and
some people who get access
to everything.
RITU SHARMA: So to
summarize and make sure--
so this is my experience
as well-- basically, that
is a false argument
when people say,
well, some access is
better than no access.
So I think what I'd
like to recognize
here is that there's a number
of different things happening
in the world, around the world.
It's from all the
major tech providers.
Whether it's
Google, whether it's
Microsoft, whether
it's Mozilla--
there are a number
of providers--
everybody is providing options
here and developing options
here.
So I'd like to make sure
people understand, especially
because this is a common
misconception, that there's
a lot happening.
And we have to let market
do what market does best.
It's competitive framework,
where there will be options.
So it's not, when they
say limited access,
if we say no to, say, the
walled garden approach,
that they're going to
be left in the dark.
There are other approaches
being designed and tested,
constantly, around the world.
Is that correct?
NIKHIL PAHWA: So I
think there's also
one more thing to
remember, what happens
to the cost of open access.
Right?
And who pays for that zero-rated
access to a few sites?
What has been
noticed-- so there's
a study from the Digital
Fuel Monitor in Europe
where they found that countries
where there is zero-rating,
and zero-rating
hasn't been banned,
and carriers are allowed
to do sponsored data,
that incentive is far greater
to do sponsored data than
to actually lower costs
of universal access.
Even in India, if
you look at it,
sponsored data makes
carriers four times the money
that open access does.
So their incentive
is essentially
to move people to
sponsored data,
to move websites into
the sponsored data packs
and away from the open web.
And cost of the
open web is actually
going to either remain high
or it is going to increase.
Because if you make four
times the money in one product
and you make one
fourth on the other,
then, you're bound
to see the difference
and either push for one or
raise the cost of the other
to a level where you feel
that you're doing justice
to your own business.
And these are legitimate
business arguments.
But we have to look at, where
this is the public good.
And what benefits
people the most?
What benefits citizens of
every country the most?
Because spectrum is
a public resource
that's been licensed
to carriers.
And they shouldn't be allowed
to carve out a private space.
They're not owners,
they're licensees.
And therefore, because
they get limited access
and they are
license oligopolies,
governments should
have the right
to essentially direct
them which way they go
and ensure that their
practices are not
discriminatory against
users who want to create.
RITU SHARMA: So that answers,
actually, my next question
I was going to ask you.
But in case you haven't
covered everything,
why should a regulator, whether
it's in India or another place,
get involved in this space?
So I think you
already answered that.
But I just wanted to make
sure if there's anything
else you can add to that.
NIKHIL PAHWA: So I think we've
seen abuse of net neutrality
in India over many years.
There are several plans which
have violated net neutrality.
And this was perpetuating--
what is happening now
was that the
carriers wanted to--
because it was a
regulated gray area,
they were pushing for regulation
to legitimize their practices.
And that would have opened the
floodgates to essentially what,
you know, you've even
seen in throttling,
which was the cablization
of the internet,
of creating packs
and creating menus
of limited access for people.
So that regulatory
consultation which the carriers
forced upon us
became an opportunity
to ensure that net
neutrality is preserved
and the openness is there.
And I think we need regulation,
because for free markets
to operate and to
flourish online,
you need some amount
of limitations
on the activities of
carriers that allow access
to those free markets.
RITU SHARMA: Interesting.
In a free market, shouldn't
a carrier or provider,
even a provider like
Google, have the right
to price their products and
services as they see fit?
NIKHIL PAHWA: I mean,
like I mentioned,
that spectrum is
a public resource.
And it's a limited
amount of spectrum
that's available to us.
And so governments license
that, because they believe
that private parties
can essentially roll out
infrastructure networks
with a profitable incentive
in a manner that
meets a public good,
not necessarily meets a
private good, in that sense.
But the rationale behind
it is that governments
aren't the best people
to build businesses.
Right?
But even then, because
not everyone has access
to that spectrum, because
it's either a high price
or there's a choice that the
government makes in terms
of who they give
that license too,
I think we need to have
control so that they don't
act in a discriminatory manner.
Because you know, like
we were seeing in India,
if all the carriers
work together,
and they start asking
for the same thing, which
allows for discrimination,
where does a consumer go?
If you start a
website-- and imagine
if you had to go to
every single carrier
and request him, hey, make my
site accessible to people--
and you had to negotiate a rate
for making a site accessible,
does that really benefit people?
It doesn't.
And so we need
regulation to ensure
that there isn't discriminatory
practice going on.
RITU SHARMA: Wonderful.
How is it different-- just to go
a little bit deeper in there--
how is it different than
the toll-free systems
that we have in America?
That argument has been
made by some people,
especially in the US.
So help us see, how is it
different than toll-free access
on phones?
NIKHIL PAHWA: OK.
So the first thing
you need to realize
is that, in India, it isn't
about the speed of access.
The internet infrastructure
is really poor.
Almost all of it is mobile.
So we're all dependent on the
mobile carriers for providing
access to the internet.
I would say that, out of about
300 million connections--
315 million, 320 million
connections-- 300 million
are effectively
mobile connections.
Now, toll-free calling is a
support system for businesses,
it isn't the entire business.
Access means that if someone
gets control about how users
access your site,
they're in a position
to then become
discriminatory in nature.
Right?
They have that power, and
they can misuse that power.
Today-- and I think we
have to look at this
in the very long term as well.
Because the way carriers
usually play this--
and we've seen this,
in India, in the past,
in case of a separate
ecosystem called
mobile value-added
services-- they
play one company versus another.
So they'll tell one company,
we'll offer you this rate.
Come on board.
And then, the competitor will
be forced to come on board.
And then, another
competitor will
be forced to come on board.
And then, who leaves?
No one blinks
first, because they
have a competitive
disadvantage to leave.
It's the prisoner's dilemma.
So you get stuck in
a situation where you
have two separate ecosystems.
And the access is controlled
entirely by the carrier,
so they have
disproportionate power.
So toll-free data isn't
merely a support system.
RITU SHARMA: Oh, I see, yes.
NIKHIL PAHWA: Whereas toll-free
calling is a support system
for an existing business.
RITU SHARMA: Well, thank
you for clarifying that.
Quite frankly, even I
did not understand that.
I heard that all the time.
And I'm like, it
kind of makes sense.
But now, thank you
for explaining that,
because I've heard
this argument a lot.
NIKHIL PAHWA: So think
about it this way.
Your business wouldn't
exist, or your website
wouldn't exist, if
you hadn't partnered
with a carrier in that case.
But in the case of
toll-free calling,
people can still
walk into your store.
RITU SHARMA: Mm-hmm.
So it's about the access.
Now, why is an open and
unrestricted internet
access important for the
startup ecosystem in India?
For innovation in India,
ground-up innovation in India?
NIKHIL PAHWA: One of
the things that we've
been hearing for
many years is about,
when is the next Google
going to come from India.
And is it going to
come from India?
Because that's a company
that the world looks up to.
And that's what's happened
in the last few years.
There's a 10,000
Startups program
that's running from NASSCOM.
The Indian government has
started a Startup India policy.
And the idea is to encourage
entrepreneurs and creators
to build for India, and
also, for Indian startups
to go global.
So there are companies like
Zomato, which bought Urbanspoon
in the US as well.
Zomato's in, now, 23 countries.
Practo is another
health care startup
which is going global as well.
So we're seeing Indian
startups go global.
The problem is
that, when you don't
have net neutrality at home,
that initial bit of freedom
that you need to
build a consumer base
and build a business
won't be there.
So what happens to
a startup ecosystem
without net neutrality
is that they shift here,
to the Bay Area.
And they move out of India into
more freer markets and more
freer economies.
So it effectively means
that Indian creators don't
create in India for India.
And that affects from a
public policy perspective.
It impacts employment.
It impacts income generation.
And for startups, it
just means that there's
an additional layer of
friction that gets created.
And that never helps.
RITU SHARMA: That's very true.
And actually, that's
the heart of the work
that we're trying to do
with several governments
that we're working on.
And the importance of
that, beyond public policy,
is really, how do we
create opportunity
in different parts of the world.
How do we encourage,
from school system up,
to create and solve
their own problems?
Because there's a lot of
other implications of that.
One is, poverty and
lack of opportunities
creates a lot of
unstable circumstances.
If you see, in the
Middle East, you see,
in some of the other places,
a thriving economic system
that can participate
in the global growth,
the digital transformation,
creates an environment
where people don't
have to come here
or there's no radicalization.
There's a lot of implications
beyond just innovation.
And people who are dealing
with the problem, who
face the problem on
a day-to-day basis
are the best-suited for
solving that problem.
It is hard to imagine a problem
that a rural person in India,
or for that matter,
Zambia is going
to have from a Stanford lab
right here, in the Bay Area.
And to be in their place and
create products and solutions
that solve that with the
resources that are available
there-- so the
contextual part of that
is really important too.
And I think that's
enabled by internet access
in creating products and
services for the local market
versus creating
products from here
and then trying to penetrate
there and scale those.
So there's a great benefit
of creating those ecosystems
as well.
NIKHIL PAHWA: And that's the
benefit of creating access.
And I think one of the problems
that zero-rating does not solve
is creating access.
So what do we need
for creating access?
We need lower spectrum costs.
We need cheaper
right of way access.
We need, say, carriers
to be incentivized
in terms of just the ability
for getting them support, like,
to the US [INAUDIBLE],
for rolling out
that infrastructure.
Zero-rating doesn't grow
the pipe, it splits the pie.
And that means that
carriers effectively just
focus on monetizing the scarcity
rather than addressing scarcity
with growth.
And so we need to
push public policy
towards fiber-optic connectivity
to villages and to small towns.
We need open spectrum available.
We need products-- I
mean, we need something
like what Google's
trying with Loon,
that brings actual
internet access instead
of just apportioning
existing bandwidth.
RITU SHARMA: So
building on zero-rating,
this is an important part.
What are the implications of
the telecom regulatory authority
of India ban on zero-rating?
Can you explain to
us what just happened
on the 8th of February, just
to continue on that thread?
NIKHIL PAHWA: Zero-rating
was not banned.
It was, essentially,
differential pricing
that was banned, which means
that carriers aren't allowed
to price access to
individual sites differently,
which means that they can't
charge a certain amount of data
charges for accessing Google
versus another set of data
charges for eBay,
and a different rate
for accessing Facebook.
And zero-rating was
just one manifestation
of differential pricing, because
zero is also a different price.
So the regulator has said that
this kind of pricing mechanism
is essentially
discriminatory in nature,
because it discriminates
between sites.
And so they've advocated access
to the internet as a whole,
because no one site
is the internet.
And they've restricted
carriers, or prevented carriers,
from doing this differential
pricing, including zero-rating.
What they have allowed
is, essentially,
intranet-based services.
So carriers can create
their own services
as long as they don't
replicate web-based services.
And they can then provide
those to their own consumers
for free.
But I think the regulator's
waiting and watching
on that particular aspect to
see whether they try and mirror
what's on the web and try and
replace what's on the web.
Because I think
what we've realized
through the course
of this debate,
and even the regulator
has, is that the internet
has to be experienced
in its entirety.
People need to be
free to go wherever
they want to go online.
And that's what brings value
over a longer period of time
instead of just some access.
RITU SHARMA: The final
question I have is,
with Google, with its scale, and
its resources available to it,
and the talented workforce that
you have all around the world,
what can Google do to lead this
conversation from the front?
What can they do to
set the market up?
And they're in a position
with the resources, might,
opportunities.
What can they do to
lead it from the front
and create an open,
unrestricted, and accessible
internet that has
enabled its own success
and many of its product lines?
What can they do?
NIKHIL PAHWA: So you know,
one of the things that Google
has done in the
past-- and this is
going to come from a
business perspective,
right-- they helped scale the
e-commerce ecosystem in India
by running shopping
festivals in partnership
with e-commerce companies.
And e-commerce has
had a great impact
on bringing people online.
If you do a road
trip to small towns--
and I do that every
couple of years--
you can see towns changing
in terms of the clothes
that people are wearing, because
they have access to that stuff.
So I think-- and if you look at
the history of internet access
in India, one site which
brought people online
was naukri.com, because they
could use that to find jobs.
So it's utilities that matter.
And I think Google
is doing a lot
to encourage the industry
in India to go online.
We need help in
providing access.
So rolling out
Loon is important.
If we can get Google
Fi, that will be fun.
That will be prevalent.
Remember that most-- mobile
connectivity in India
is metered.
And there are data caps
on wireline access.
And there are only 15 million
wireline broadband internet
connections in
India on wireline.
So I think helping public policy
and pushing the government
to improve wireline
access is one.
Because the entire
focus is on mobile,
because that's a quicker win.
But if we think very long
term, I think Google needs to--
and I would really
appreciate it if they could--
come in and help shape
policy for improving
the quality of access.
Reports on latency,
reports on throttling,
all of that information
would help us
understand what's
actually going on.
Because people like
me don't have access
to what's happening
at the network layer.
And I don't think there's
enough data available for us
to push public policy on that.
RITU SHARMA: Well, thank you.
I want to thank all of
you for joining us today.
I want to leave you
inspired and encourage,
I hope, to be part
of a movement which
makes internet open, accessible,
and unrestricted for all people
to participate in creation
of wealth and for prosperity,
for finding opportunities,
like I did and you did,
and using this resource
to lift each other
and the vast majority of
this world that still remains
in poverty out of poverty.
I want to thank
our host, Anamika.
Thank you for making this
happen at a very short notice.
Thank you for providing us the
platform and an opportunity
to share our perspective
with Google and folks
all over the world, wherever
you are listening to us from.
And what you can do to
partner and support,
I hope you're
inspired to speak up,
to join the movement wherever
you are in the world,
to be part of this, and speak
up when you see policies
that anti-competitive,
and be part
of the movement in general.
So thank you very
much for your time.
And I will see if
anybody has questions.
But thank you again.
AUDIENCE: I largely
agree with, I think,
your stance on this kind
of zero-rating generally.
But I am curious-- and I
could be wrong on this,
but my understanding is
that TRAI decision-- TR--
the regulatory decision banning
zero-rating-- or differential
pricing, like you say--
also bans Wikipedia Zero.
And what is your
stance on something
that's so clear-cut, like,
this very bright line that
bans everything?
Do you think that's
necessarily--
I mean, what is your
stance on that, I guess?
NIKHIL PAHWA: So our
stance on Wikipedia Zero
is that Wikipedia is not the
only most beneficial service
out there.
Right?
So if you look at
the Khan Academy,
why not the Khan Academy?
And so the moot question
is, who decides.
Who decides what's
great and what's not?
And so one of the things that's
come in in the regulation
is that emergency
services are fine,
because those are necessary.
And outside of that, there
are hundreds and thousands
of nonprofits who are doing
great work in their own way.
So it's a question of whether
we want to give carriers
disproportionate power.
Nothing against Wikipedia
Zero, but we also
don't want a situation
where they're
used to sugarcoat more
harmful ways of zero-rating.
And that's what was
essentially happening
over a period of time.
We have a clear,
bright-lined regulation now.
And one solution for
this is for Wikipedia
to separate itself
from zero-rating.
So they can do low bandwidth
access to Wikipedia
and give data to people.
Or carriers can give
free data to people.
There are other ways
of providing access
to the internet as a whole.
And let people decide.
You've seen what's happening in
Angola with Wikipedia as well.
I mean, with zero-rated
access, there
are people who are using
it to do file sharing.
So we never know what people
will do with the kind of access
that they have.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
NIKHIL PAHWA: Thanks.
RITU SHARMA: Any
parting words, Nikhil?
NIKHIL PAHWA: Well, I just
love what the World Wide Web
Foundation says, which is,
all of the internet for all
of the people all of the time.
And I don't think
we should compromise
between any one of
those three phases
and choose one
versus the others.
Thank you.
RITU SHARMA: Well,
thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
NIKHIL PAHWA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]